[Music]
the world is remembering princess diana
this morning a lot of people remember
where they were when she was killed 20
years ago today in a car crash in paris
her death at the age of 36 she was only
36 years old shocked the world and
triggered a flood of grief and anger too
princess diana's sons prince william and
prince harry visited a growing memorial
outside her former home of kensington
palace mark phillips is now outside
kensington palace with more on the
legacy that she left behind mark good
morning
good morning well the crowds have
gathered for diana again much smaller
this time than they were 20 years ago
when this was the scene of mass mourning
for the princess and frankly it's taken
just about that long to try to
understand what her life and her death
meant
the only official recognition of the
anniversary was the brief public
appearance of her two sons and william's
wife kate in the memorial garden
dedicated to diana
and with a small crowd of well-wishers
at the palace gate
it was all but a faint echo of the mass
expression of public grief that had
followed diana's shocking death
such a waste isn't it
i think i'm just speaking for everybody
feel like everybody
it's just incredibly sad
back then it became more than a tragedy
for two young boys william was 15 and
harry 12 at the time it was a national
psycho drama that seemed to shake the
foundations of the monarchy of a queen
who it was said had waited too long
before acknowledging the nation's sorrow
of the heir to the throne prince charles
the villain of the peace still being
blamed for the breakdown of the marriage
and of the people's princess who had
seemed to single-handedly drag the
stuffy royal family into the modern
world and who had more or less become
its brand she touched our hearts in life
and death
the fractures and the bond between the
royals and the people that diana's death
revealed became the story then in some
ways though her death is proving more
difficult for them to handle than her
life was
20 years later the flowers are gone and
that great flood of shock and grief that
had swept britain has long since receded
leaving a kind of sad nostalgia behind
william kate and the kids now live in
kensington palace to which diana had
been exiled after the divorce and all
those changes to the monarchy they
turned into mostly a question of style
just goes to show what a massive figure
she was and still is royal correspondent
roya
in terms of press interest in terms of
the way the younger royals go about
their job so she is that linchpin she
does still hold it together she is still
that focal point
somebody who has not been a focal point
lately is prince charles the next king
who has decided many think wisely to
keep silencer in this commemoration as
for diana's sons prince william and
harry they too have decided to
commemorate this event in private
maurice mark phillips in london thank
you i remember the way the news traveled
back then you get home and turn on the
tv versus the smart phone yes that's how
we found out it happened in the middle
of the night i remember being up but i
like how mark said sad nostalgia is
right people were so worried about
william and harry at the time they were
so young how are they going to turn out
it's good to see that they've apparently
turned out okay sure did she'd be very
proud she would